a new study in Japan is saying that
people who stare at screens all day long
laptop screens specifically
phone screen they are actually changing
the liquid
in their eyes this is really deranged
they're changing tear fluid
the similar to people who have a disease
known as dry eye
but look at some info on the stand the
protein
and youth c5a see what might be the
protein secreted by cells in the upper
eyelid makes up part in the normally
occurring mucus layer or tear film they
keep the I voiced we all have this
that's why you can blink
and it keeps bad destin being that your
eyes study participants with the most
screen time
had MU c5a sea levels nearing those are
people
with diagnose dry eye so when I was
reading this
a literally I had just woke up
and do you guys go to your phones right
when you wake up because I do it
it's a bad habit I've been trying to
break it and I look at my phone
and there are times especially purse
thing in the morning I wake up and my
eyes are dry
and I'm literally I got one eye and I
lower the light on the iPhone yet and
I'm go like this like
wet weather that so this is happening
miss Israel
what do you think I why do you keep your
eyes moist
well I know the first thing I thought
others can be so many people are going
this is do with it be at that's not true
shut up
but those are people who don't want to
accept that the things that they're
doing
are bad for them yeah so its I think
it's it's probably true I'm willing to
up go for it maybe put the phone down
for another half hour before we go
do you have that you do you have any
moments where you realize that your eyes
a bother you cuz the screen at the new
thing now is everyone's making their
screens darker at night
somehow I don't actually yeah I'm but
we know this is real because what other
guy in China recently that the taxes
retroactive effect thing I wouldn't
girlfriend literally yet
her gonna pop off next any see like
was insane or were rooting are tear
ducts were
our eyeballs are popping out over
scolding me maybe we put the phone down
for five minutes
yeah I mean our are you doing this are
you walking around with a power-play
saying also directing this all day long
oh there I I'm walked into class might
my lovely I nowhere and downed it done
but when I read them I if out a little
bit sensitive unlike
do I like diagnosed dry
there are so many other things that are
so much worse than live like
girl I Friday
you're gonna go out a dry eye community
which they're being Breitling
right about that should make the law and
either I kinda laughter like
it felt like a dust that a lot of course
if you're staring at a computer screen
to your telephone or anything excess is
gonna be back for you
I just don't care that much about dry
yeah
stock market girl with lb eyes right now
was walking into glad
wait till the day you operate developing
your phone goes right in your I gathered
been up there then you'll hear up is
there anything we can do to fight this
that could work because we all do it we
all do it there is no doubt
you know to me and I i said it about the
wake up being I've been trying to shut
down I try to hide 9 o'clock now I've
really been trying I'm not always
successful
to stop looking at Twitter so I'm doing
you know my little more I and II barely
open to an Instagram every third day now
every day I'm just tryna
too slowly do it I am but do you try to
fight it in a way
I discover encroaching but I might I
don't speak for
up another when she's going to like
provide the non stop crying yeah I think
this is I think this is really good
information and they're not even say
Michael got everybody pair Billy
23 now say yes your doctor may be
totally ravaged
do do you yet what about you are you
doing anything to fight it out if you
admit it you freely admit it
yeah II more so the type person by okay
when I'm at home it's family time let's
put away our Father dinner time is put
away our Father but not because I'm
scared
dry i connect with a broom people I
don't wanna always be
you know doing it for the like I got 10
like get back to dinner time when you
talk to your family
that I use a dry eye he said he'd rather
I such a benefit dry
up